[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the lehigh pen
show it is powered of course by icon
plus capital the vc firm aubry great to
have you how you doing today
i'm doing well thanks for having me on
leah i'm so excited
we haven't talked yeah i know i'm really
excited to jump in before we do i just
want to let everybody know that this
is um sponsored by blockfi so you can
actually get up to 250
when you sign up um which is pretty
great right now because i mean
everything is crashing
so a little bit of money there isn't too
bad um
but yeah aubry how are you doing where
are you based right now
so right now i'm not my normal setup um
obviously i think
i film all the tv from like my house i'm
at my grandmother's shore house in new
jersey in like southern new jersey
that's why
it's very humid and crazy down here but
um
yeah it's i don't know if you know like
the jersey shore
i mean they used to have like a show
about it but it's not i know
it's not like the show at all people
like like
just a bunch of like italians like fist
pumping the whole time it's not that at
all but
oh it's not that like that's what we
think it is in the uk
it's not that it's actually really nice
like short tap and it's gotten like a
bad rap
i'm sure there's like parts of like the
uk that
people like chalk up to some sort of
like stereotype and it's like
absolutely nothing like that but yeah
anyways down here
fixing up my grandmother's house and
working at the same time right now
nice well i kind of want to go into all
of this stuff i mean i know that
you know the markets are crashing right
now and we'll get into that but i want
to talk a little bit
about you how you got into crypto um
i really love what you do i think it's
really different it's so
current and i also love try lolly the
brand that you've built
so i want to go back a little bit um and
on san francisco how did you get into
crypto then how did you land
with tri lolly so
crypto i got into back in 2016
and it was sort of just right out of
college i was looking to be a journalist
i was
um kind of trying to figure out what i
wanted to do with my life and
i did political pr and then sort of
found this company that was
doing crypto pr and before that like
maybe a few months before that
i had been personally investing in
crypto bitcoin ethereum litecoin
just you know sort of like the top of
the coin market cap
but wait before before you got into
crypto you were actually investing
yeah i was investing well i mean before
i worked in crypto like maybe three
months
i was sort of investing
and i had roommates and friends and
people that were
like very like had gone full into crypto
and so i started to follow them because
they were actually working
in financial services and if they were
sort of looking towards this new asset
class it was probably
a signal of things changing and so i
think i bought my first
bitcoin actually at a bitcoin atm down
in
which is usually not where someone buys
their first bitcoin which is very funny
um
at bitcoin atm down in like the lower
side of manhattan they have this atm
machine and i and i
bought there and then most of the i
bought on exchanges but
yeah that's been that's been the
beginning so i've been in this space for
about five
years and then with lolly i had a friend
uh he's still my friend his name's louis
and he
connected me with alex and said you need
to talk to alex he's really building
something great here and i worked on a
lot of projects that i thought were too
early for where the market was and when
i
heard about lolly i was i said this is a
great entry point and i
you just know when you hear a winner
like you're like this is going to work
i very much believe in this and it's
needed
and so that's sort of the background
there and i guess i should probably
explain lolly to people who
yeah where um so lolly is a bitcoin
rewards company that gives you free
bitcoin when you shop
online from over a thousand merchants
and it's only in the us right now but
we're going to
expand internationally so these are
places like macy's priceline
harry's chewy and you can earn
free bitcoin on every purchase so it's a
way to passively invest in bitcoin and
own the asset without
sort of feeling the hurt sometimes if
you're putting your own money
into it uh so it's good for newbies it's
good for people who've been in this
space for a long time
and i've sort of saw the way that i
think alex
beautifully put it one time is we've
seen these different ways of waves of
adoption we've seen
uh mining obviously the original way to
procure bitcoin and then people buying
on exchanges which was like more of the
cycle and then there's sort of another
wave that's come through and it's
it's a newer sort of uh
retail investor that just wants exposure
to the asset but they don't
know if they really want to put money
into it and that's through earnings so
it's sort of the third way of the wave
of bitcoin adoption through lolly
yeah i think it's really cool i think
it's it's really different to kind of
regard it as a new wave of bitcoin mass
adoption because it's just not something
which i think
is an obvious play really is it because
you know we always talk about like
education but
i think the best way to get to give
anybody anything or to get them on board
is to give them something for free
like i am a huge fan of crypto.com
and i have their card but i i never put
the money down or anything somebody that
i worked with was like leia you need to
get on board
so just here it is you know and i think
i think that's the best way to do it but
what you've done with um trilogy is so
interesting because i feel like you
really tap into
um the culture the online culture and i
think that
it's it's not just like a fun game it's
actually like a really smart business
strategy
so what would you say some of the key
things are
to growing a brand online i like what
you said there because i think people
sometimes not saying everyone thinks
this
sees memes in the way people have run
accounts as sort of a joke and it's
it's silly and you're not taking
seriously when it's actually very
calculated
and it's obviously done for reasons of
course we want to have a good time we're
not you know sitting back here
calculating every single meme that we
put out on the on the channel
but there's a lot of sort of old age
traditional which is sort of like
you know revolting against the old way
of media the old way of connecting with
your
consumers is being so professional and
uptight and buttoned up
and that's sort of not the way the world
is anymore so
things are shifting financially but also
the way companies market
and um sorry just not on tandem there
because i i no go for it
but um what was the original question
how do we
yeah so i basically i'm asking how do
you um
how important is that to growing a brand
or like what would you say the most
important thing is to growing a brand i
know
because i'm saying like you guys
obviously focus on the meme culture
quite a bit
um so how so what would you say the key
features are to growing a brand online
and growing
a presence um online yeah i where
we were we started in 2018 and so that's
a bear market
and people really are just looking for
entertainment and i think there's a lot
of people now creators that are doing a
great job of this
and it wasn't really prevalent in the
crypto community because you kind of
have to get over this hump
of trust with a lot of financial
institutions
before you you know you lolly is a
custodian in many ways
and you know we hold a lot of bitcoin
and but we come up
we approach the uh customer in a
different way
than you know some other financial
institutions but now you see exchanges
sort of behaving in a similar manner you
the way binance is running their account
it's they sort of like everyone's sort
of just copied off of like
sort of the lolly model in a way they're
like it is okay to make jokes online
especially
because a lot of crypto is sort of a
joke sometimes not like not the
assets but some of the i mean some of
the names of these tokens are absolutely
insane and
the things that go on with elon musk or
whatever if you're not staying
culturally relevant on these topics
you're losing a great opportunity to
communicate with a large amount of
people
and so i think that people have begun to
realize these a lot
realize this and a lot of um exchanges
and companies in the crypto space have
adopted it
but it was not a thing this was not a
thing for
companies for a while but yeah the the
lolly brand should
the reason we we make it so uh
comfortable
and fun and whatever you want to call it
is because it should be you know
bitcoin should be approachable it should
feel that way you want to feel good
about the brand when you go
and use the product you you want to feel
like you want to
shop online and get bitcoin back so it's
all these things to encourage it through
the name through the branding the color
it's like a periwinkle
purple you know things that weren't
traditionally done or used in the space
so
i think the combination of all those
things make it more likeable and it's
called lolly it was never taking itself
very seriously in the first place but
you can take yourself seriously
in the same token if that makes sense
yeah no i think it does and i think that
um it's just really interesting because
there is a huge shift in the way that we
do things and i think that really
started with our generation
um you know we were kind of just i guess
it's because social media
social media made things far more
informal which meant that moving into
the workplace
things sort of became more informal and
i just think it's like a slow kind of
evolution
um you know it's just so it's just so
interesting to see and like
it's particularly with crypto because
everything is alternative like when this
thing started you had major
billionaires and ceos doing interviews
and t-shirts and
there was no formality from the
beginning um
and i think that really like annoyed
some people and maybe it's just like a
tech thing as well because
mark zuckerberg back in the day you know
would turn up and
t-shirts maybe it's a tech thing it's a
little bit of a tech thing i think but i
think crypto's taking it to
the next level there's always that you
know i think a lot of people come over
from the wall street
side of things they still wear like the
suits and whatever but
mostly you're seeing a shift a
generational shift on a lot of different
areas through finance through the way
you communicate the way people work
and so it's all sort of happening right
now and it was probably pushed
uh pushed through and like
faster i guess because of coco because
people
had to be kind of less formal and you
couldn't go into an office and all those
things so uh people are learning
that rather quickly but you say
something really interesting about the
suit okay so i
i don't i've seen all the name names and
keep it professional but i did interview
somebody
recently no never i get to meet somebody
recently and
he was like in a full-blown suit and it
was actually the first time
in over a year i'd interviewed somebody
who was in a full-blown suit
and even my editor said to me i didn't
trust him i go do you know what it's the
suit
that's why you didn't trust him i'm
serious i'm absolutely serious it's
because
you're not used to it and everybody's so
informal and like you said it's about
like
being relatable and creating something
which doesn't scare people off like who
wears a suit in crypto anymore
that's true i actually would that's
funny because there's this
there's this social experiment of you
know if someone is
hurt on the sidewalk and they're wearing
a suit would you go help them rather
than someone who's not wearing a suit
and that looks
you know maybe you know kind of
whatever i don't know um and so that
but now if you flip that around and say
you know if you're interviewing someone
or you're
they're coming for a job or you're just
meeting them are they wearing a suit or
not
it does put people in a weird mindset
like put off sometimes
this is like too serious of a
conversation um that's like i guess
that's just the boomers
i don't know yeah he was a boomer but
like i think what's also really
interesting is
before i started to be more independent
in the space
the first crypto company i worked for
did everything the traditional way it
was so formal and so uptight
and unfortunately the company didn't
succeed and i think that's the problem i
think that's why
i think that's all though is that the uk
do you feel like the uk because i lived
in it wasn't a uk company it wasn't
an american american company okay so i
worked in dublin not an island
not a part of the uk but um it for a few
months
and i felt like the office that i worked
in and
everyone there was so dressed up all the
time
lovely people lovely bunch very great
so dressed up all the time like wearing
suits every day to the office and this
was
two years ago that i was working there
and it was a crypt it was crypto company
but very very dressed up and it was just
odd to me none of that made sense we're
working on
with crypto clients uh anyway so
no i'm with you yeah no no i'm
definitely
sorry i can't hear you like i thought
this was an irish thing maybe
and i don't know no i think i think i
think it's just like an office thing if
i'm honest
um i think it's an office kind of thing
but
so okay so i want to get your thoughts
on why what do you think so effective
about it so it's obviously relatable but
i kind of had this whole idea in my head
and i made this video and i was sort of
comparing
it to like finance in terms of like
supply and demand and i had this theory
that
there's a real lack of like happiness
and entertainment in this world
and so i felt people would gravitate
towards things which
are lighter and funnier and sillier um
what do you think i for yeah there's
been a bunch of financial meme accounts
that have
basically popped up over the past few
years and it's
this shared struggle and strife that
traditional finances
throughout but then cryptos crypto memes
have been around for a long time uh the
enter the community is also just more
plugged in online than
other communities so they're they're
always online they're day trading
and so they can make memes they
understand culture
and for that's more on the community
side but for a company side
really a meme is just a message that
you're getting across in a
in a shorter way and especially on
twitter you have a character limit
and you can only really get out what
people can
get in in probably a second scroll down
their timeline so whatever you have to
say it needs to be funny needs to be
convincing
it needs to or evoke some sort of
emotion get something across or else
your meme's not good
so people like like i said people are
downplaying how
what a strategy it is but if you go look
on instagram now there's a lot of
companies that
are sort of hiding their product within
memes
yeah you feel like you're reading a meme
and it's funny
but it's secretly branded and you
wouldn't know it
unless you sort of really looked into it
and you see that their products at the
end but
the content is so good that you're
willing to share it and the real
metric used to be likes and uh
retweets or just likes on instagram but
really it's the shared
button or the saved button on instagram
and that's what we found so we run a
meme account on lolly's instagram and
every day we rank the best bitcoin memes
and if we look at i've looked at the
metrics of it the
the amount of shares that it got the
last one we just did roasted elon musk
is crazy people love memes they love to
share they love to send it to their
friends i'm sure you do when you're on
instagram or some
you know you find a funny meme you want
to share it and the engagement is so
much higher compared to something that
would just be promoting your
brand if that makes sense you're still
yeah they're still coming they're coming
for the content
yeah and i think i actually don't think
it's anything too new um
because i think what they're selling you
is a lifestyle
and i believe that's always been the
case when it comes to advertising like
you can watch
the most incredible ad on tv right it's
so good
and then you're like what on earth are
they advertising and then right at the
end mcdonald's
you know so so they're so they're
selling you you know like
a lifestyle and a community and i guess
memes is the same thing it's just done
differently
but in terms of meme coins this is
something that
you know has totally blown up recently
so you've been in the space longer that
i have
so i want to get your thoughts um things
like doge and safe moon
yeah safe moon shiba inu and all those
fun cute things
um is this is it is this just
standard bull market or is this
part of this evolving internet culture
i think a lot of it is the bull market
did you see the one i
saw it last night little zam the rapper
came out with pubecoin
did you see that so i saw somebody was
about to do a live stream
i saw someone's about to do a live
stream and i was like wait wait wait i'm
confused
so what was that yeah i i didn't look
into the token economics or whatever
that pube is but uh you know little zan
put out and that's when i
was like i need to close my laptop and
and get off twitter for the day which is
obviously impossible but
uh yeah these these tokens ass
yummy safe moon i think there's
there are some tokens and there's some
protocols are being made
that have some promise but
not not all of these i think they're
going to fall away you know by the
wayside the way
that the sort of ico is happened
i can't even name anything that's really
around anymore and
even that during that time i was pretty
young and
new to the space i could even tell with
literal no experience and
experience at all in the space that this
was a was just
not the ico market was like a bubble and
there was
no cap icos and then they just rebranded
to stos and then
where are these projects today what have
they done four years later there's
nothing
for most of them some of the tokens are
around um
that were created then but i i can only
name a few so
i do think a lot of it is the bull
market but i do
think that there is a lot of creators
that are finding ways to
optimize payments and and they're trying
to figure it out i don't think anyone
has it perfectly nailed down or trying
to figure out the ecosystem
but when i was out in l.a there is so
many celebrities and people that are
interested
in in basically creating their own coin
or creating their own crypto project
they're very into crypto
which is interesting because i'm always
in new york and the crypto conversation
in new york is a lot different than the
creator uh culture conversation that's
in la
so it's sort of dynamic in the united
states right now i would say
yeah my brother's actually been spending
the last three months in la
um he's a big tick tocker or whatever
um and yeah we'll talk about that
another time
anyway he is like so into crypto
everybody in la all the creators i'm
hearing are holding doge
um they are all like he's got his own
yacht
which is if if anyone doesn't know the
yat is when you have the emojis
which belongs to you so like a phone
number but it like belongs to you and it
can't be replaced
i mean it can't be copied nobody else
can have that that combination of emojis
um i think he's actually going to miami
and i'm supposed to be there but he's
getting to go there you know so he's
really in the miami bitcoin conference
there's another one
there's an nft one around the same time
so he's gonna go to that one also on the
same day
um yeah it's insane but like
speaking of doge okay um this one's
really interesting elon musk has backed
it
so i just want to get your your thoughts
on it the way i kind of
where i stand on this i think most
people know is that i'm obviously
very aware it's a coin it's a meme
coin and it has no value like i've
always been very open about that
um but what i do but i predicted that
elon musk would try
to work with so-called developers to
make it something and i'm just
i'm intrigued to see what happens i
don't know what are your thoughts on on
dage
i have a lot of thoughts on just elon
musk in general and and why he operates
the way he does
and i think that people react very
emotionally to what he does every day
online
and he's he's a little unhinged
do you think i think a little bit i
think he
there are some parallels to the way elon
not to make it political
tweets but and trump it's i knew you're
gonna say that i was way
far it's just a little bit of like
and not quite to that extent dave
portnoy dave tries to be
sort of on that level but his is like a
little bit more contrived because he's
always
he has a production team that really
puts stuff out there whereas
trump and elon just really shoot from
the hip on all their tweets you know
that they were just sort of thought out
of
five seconds before they went out and so
do i think it's a pr stunt i mean tesla
was profitable
on you know in q1 mostly because of
adding bitcoin to their balance sheet
and so
yeah i in in some ways i do think he's
going to
perhaps sell a little bit by low
you know i could see that happening i
also see that the community has really
pissed him off like i think the fight
that went on
last week was insane you know he really
people were can be awful online i think
elon probably has tough skin but the
like absolute crying from grown men
online it's just ridiculous you don't
need a hero
to champion your coin you don't need a
mascot this is not why we got into the
space i'm so sick of hearing
people cry because it you know the price
dipped
five percent now it's like literally
fifty percent or i don't even know where
we were from the market top but you know
there are there are worse problems in
the world and i get it's just funny
meaning and
and all of that and elon's wrong a lot
about you know a lot of information he's
putting out there so people want to
explain
why there are you know renewable energy
resources for mining and a lot of that
is being done
but at the same time you know you're
giving attention to a screaming child at
a point and you got you got to know and
to pull back
in my opinion so you just like can't
give him all the attention
it would be so much funnier if people
just ignored it could you imagine
i totally agree with you i think that um
i think so firstly it was so complicated
what went on
because i definitely agree the first
main issue
is is just spreading the fud about you
know
the environmental concerns when it comes
to bitcoin that was so unneeded
and i understand you know i think peter
mccormack was saying that a lot of
bitcoin has
spent a lot of time debunking all of
this and for somebody to come out with
so much influence to
basically echo all that all that
misinformation i get it it's horrible
and
and and all that stuff but it just it
went too far
and you know if bitcoin there's so much
wrong here so like
it's supposed to be decentralized and it
is decentralized
but then one man shouldn't be able to
move the markets like that
exactly i totally agree with that and i
think that's a problem
if it can be moved i also think the
bitcoiners some of the people in the
community that were screaming and
yelling and crying
it's almost like in pr what i teach or
like what i've
sometimes if there's a problem a crisis
comes problem you know something's
happening to a company and
you know you don't want to bring
attention to it almost talking about the
issue
and continuing to acknowledge it brings
more bad press to the issue because
there's a lot of people that probably
didn't really
you know care outside of the crypto
community i know maybe they didn't see
it
maybe they didn't even see it exactly
and so but then
it gets exacerbated by the community
because they throw a
you know an absolute fit for three days
and so then i mean
story and it's and i don't think people
understand how that works
you give you add fuel to the fire it
becomes a battle
elon musk versus everyone dogecoin
versus bitcoin you know and then it goes
on fox news and people are talking about
it and that's
on fox fox business they've been
covering everything cnbc and
that is how the stories get made where
as if you would have just ignored
perhaps elon and he just said he had
some environmental concerns and
you know a few people talked about it it
probably wouldn't have been as good
so i think sometimes the community and
there's nothing you can do about it
because there's so many people part of
this community now
can get so riled up about everything you
know
and it's not always beneficial for
for you know the media coverage the the
community
a lot of things but like back to your
point one person should not be able to
influence a market yeah really and so i
think that
you know that still is a high concern
for many people and so i think that's
worth sort of realizing now
um but the dip today you know i'm not
sure even
anyone knows why it's stipping so much
at this point you said perhaps china
yeah i keep hearing about china um but
okay so do you think that
do you think he was doing some some kind
of pr stunt here or do you think his
actual concerns were genuine because
this is a smart man and i've said the
same thing about donald trump like i've
always said donald trump is a genius
yeah and people always say he's an idiot
but he's not and you know
elon musk is obviously really
intelligent guy how do you
buy bitcoin not know about the
environmental concerns
um and then and then say no we won't
take we won't accept it anymore
meanwhile you're launching rockets to
the moon
yeah which is not environmentally
friendly so
did he know yeah i mean the carbon
footprint for every single rocket that
goes out is
you know i think there's some stat how
many trips around the earth but
i thought you were going to give me i
thought you're going to give me a stat
there i was excited
i know nothing off the top of my head
unfortunately i'm not an energy expert
but i did read that
uh i mean there are tesla's a publicly
traded company they have
lawyers they do due diligence they they
would have to look into
unless things run a lot differently and
they can you can think about these
companies
um i don't know if this is off a little
bit it feels like the camera is like no
you're good
matched up with me okay there's a
there's a lot of companies that you
think are run
super efficiently and you peel back the
you know the veil and you're like oh wow
it's not actually run
as well as you think it is that would be
hard to imagine at tesla
because i do think alaska is very smart
he's been successful
uh if he has environmental concerns
maybe he does
uh but the way i'm seeing comms run
at tesla i mean he put out a note
statement that wasn't even a press
release it was on it was on like a
notebook
but isn't that what we were saying
earlier though isn't that just like part
of
the new style to be more relatable and
not seem so
distant and formal when you have
shareholders though you have to
you have to put out a press release
because you have to
buy people so there's actually a
protocol with press releases
and when you de-list or change change
anything you're supposed to let people
know because they're publicly traded and
there's regulation
with you know public trade companies but
since he didn't actually sell any of the
bitcoin supposedly
um i that's just taunting the market
then
at that point and just causing
controversy and
to be honest his whole backing behind
doge i don't
like does he actually want to accept
that as payment for space like i do i
believe it yeah i do
you really and then what does that
become
and then it becomes a serious point okay
listen right i could be wrong
doge's is a piece of paper because i saw
you i saw you put out a tweet about this
i want you to explain the tweets yeah i
you were like which tweet i've done so
many it was about
elon uh accepting doge as like a space
token or was like being the you know
currency of mario okay
so this is why this is where i look at
it like this guy is a narcissist okay
this guy wants to be the best thing
he has totally revolutionized the
the way that we we transact right he he
started paypal that's
incredible crypto aside um you know
spacex
spacex is insane like if we just take a
second to think about it
you know i actually remember your a
tweet that you made um
i don't know why i remember it but i
just remember it when when it went to
the moon
no she went to sorry and go to me when i
went to when it went up to space
you tweeted i can't believe you know an
individual has done this
you know on their own i remember you
tweeted it right i was like yeah she's
like yeah she's right isn't that just
like insane so what he's done is
is unbelievable and i'm getting a kind
of
energy that he doesn't want to be part
of a movement like he wants his own
movement okay like bitcoin isn't his
bitcoin is everyone's and bitcoin
belongs to bitcoin belongs to the og's
and it's everyone's okay
like he isn't the father of bitcoin
michael saylor right now has been able
to become like
this so self-proclaimed god elon musk
would have to take
second seat to that i really don't think
that's what he wants i really think it
comes from a narcissistic place like
he called himself the doge father he
wants to be king
of whatever is coming next and so he has
the power the influence and the
intelligence
to make something now i'm not saying
it's going to replace bitcoin this is
where everybody kind of like
misunderstood
bitcoin is bitcoin i'm not saying he's
going to replace it bitcoin is still
that store of value
but right now bitcoin isn't great when
it comes to being that global medium of
exchange like it's just not
um it's a and don't talk about the
lightning network that might work in
some places but it's it's
am i'm using like network nodes the
majority of people i know use it no
um so i can imagine he creates this
internet currency like
we understand crypto is borderless okay
that's fantastic
but we need it to be cheap like i'm
sorry
but like i i get paid mostly in bitcoin
but one of the companies i work with
they just pay me a little bit of money
and it sometimes i should just do it in
bitcoin cash so we just do it in
litecoin
because otherwise we're wasting too much
money yeah so
we need something and we need it now and
this is what i was getting to i'm sort
of saying like
the lightning network like bitcoin came
one time but the lightning network is
too late
yes we need something now and so i feel
like elon musk is trying to fill that
hole
now so i agree with the narcissism
at that point you know i think you make
a really good point i think
it's it comes from not a genuine
place or wherever it comes from an ego
like that needs to be you know and
there's a lot of ceos and men out there
that
feel like they have done that and trump
had a huge ego too
like he can be smart and sort of an
opportunistic
person who ca you know capitalize
basically on like a group of people
who needed a leader at a time and so
elon has a very cult following and
they'll follow him to like the ends of
the earth that are not in crypto and
some that are in crypto and so i agree i
think he he sort of did
no one's late to bitcoin but he's not no
g he
he he came in did he he first bought in
february
it was right after the example it was
the day after the super bowl that he
announced i remember
and so i mean announcing in 2021
it was cool he was a hero for a second
but yeah he wants to
lead a revolution not just sort of join
and so
there's a lot of other you know who
knows what goes on in that brain
but um and especially i mean the fact
that he took the snl
bit that also like lends itself to the
argument that he's an absolute
narcissist because like
he is like who goes on like a tech ceo
going on snl
unheard of like stephen i mean what
no absolutely and i also think like okay
there's it's one thing revolutionizing
the world okay
but it's another thing being the person
that does that like
that is something else you know being
the person behind paypal being the
person
behind spacex like there's something
else the argument then
like why not create his own coin why
get behind doge if that like again we
know he's been pumping
like why doesn't he just do his own okay
so
from what i've read and this is like
really really like
brief is that it would be very difficult
because
there would be a lot of regulatory
issues because of tesla
and everything it would just be very
very difficult
um he can and i think if he can't make
doge
to the if he can't get doge to where he
wants it to be he will make his own coin
so i think doge is his first is his
first thing but i then just skip
doge because like the gamble of trying
to get everyone then you get everyone
like then you get all these doge holders
toddlers out there
and like you have to basically
transition them to a new coin it seems
like just
trim the fat make your own coin and call
it a day and get that going
because by the time you ever get to mars
you get to that point
i feel like you'd want that coin ready
and trading but whatever
i don't know what he's up to i it's
honestly just so annoying i just want to
mute his name also the fact that
fighting with a man named elon is just
like the funniest thing
to me no jabs at his name but it's just
like
fighting elon all day i know
from a pr perspective um i remember who
tweeted it maybe
it was like his name's jack sparrow or
something on that tonight
he said this is like a really he said
this is like a really bad move
and i was sort of like what are you
talking about nobody outside of crypto
knows what's going on he can he can
on bitcoin but like
nobody knows um why he's actually wrong
nobody cares about
you know bitcoin mining being
geographically independent i mean
do you really think this was a bad pr
move i just don't even think it matters
i think that the is actually a great
opportunity
i think nick carter did a great job of
explaining a lot of the
you know the research done behind proof
of work and i think
yeah a lot of people think that the
transactions you are using the most
energy when it's actually the mining
uh that is so there's this idea that oh
wow every time i send
a transaction or a remittance to my
family across seas that i'm using a
large amount of energy and i think
debunking that fact and just talking
about how people it
you know it's it's advantageous for
miners to look for renewables
on their end you know of course well as
you know why why would they want to rack
up a crazy electric bill
when they could install solar panels and
and do whatever they can to make
it easier for them so i think that
that's really hard
again the ma the main conversation of
people out there they probably don't
understand that or care to understand
that they just need to know the facts so
really on a pr end it's really giving
people bullet points of this is what's
happening
this is what's currently going on um and
this is like debunked or untrue but
it doesn't help that elon tweets about
it
but at least he's not going on
interviews yet knock on wood
talking about it because it'll be way
worse i think everyone
in the millennials and the people in the
tech community and everyone sort of that
we
are talking about is on twitter whereas
the people that would it would really
bother would be people that watch cable
television
and so as long as they're not really
involved in all the mess that's okay but
i mean the price did
drop significantly by the way what
where's the price now we've been on this
so as we speak at 35 853
okay so yeah i want to get your thoughts
so
um you know we're diving into a bear
market
[Music]
um there could be i don't know i thought
i thought the bull market was going to
go through summer
and so i don't actually think so i think
it's a huge
dip um and i think we rally after this
slowly
i it'd be interesting dynamic if at the
bitcoin miami conference
and also consensus which is the the last
week of may
just the attitude in the air because i
think they're you know hoping for a
different sort of situation maybe like a
70k bitcoin but
i don't think it's a bear market
yet but i think we will have one yeah no
i'm with you i think that
um the pr this dip is pretty wild
you know it was expected a lot of people
were expecting this you know people were
saying we're gonna get a 50
correction um and so the what i've
what i think what i've heard what seems
to be a common kind of agreement here is
that
we're going to have this crazy dip and
then one last shoot to the moon
basically
um people are still yeah fingers crossed
people are still hoping for 100k this
year um
why not we're not even yeah you're not
halfway through
yeah it's it's still may it's still very
early
i think it's actually healthy though
because it the market and just the
atmosphere was getting
crazy and i think that everyone needs
like a cold shower
like a cold bucket of water thrown on
them and
hopefully everyone can like relax a
little bit or like
sober up from the hysteria that was
happening because it was absolutely bad
for
for periods of time yeah i think
everybody needs humbling a bit you know
with those damn laser eyes
the community just needs to chill we
need humbling of it
get humbled yeah and i i'm humbled right
now too because
uh yeah i was you know i've obviously
been buying but then was buying on the
way up too just because
just it was so that i was like oh my
gosh
i throw all my like free cat i can't
even buy most of this dip because
i don't even have any like capital like
throw into it like i don't know what to
do so um
anyway yeah i think it's healthy i think
i'm very
you know grateful for a correction it's
a great opportunity to buy and i don't
think this is the end of the 2021
cycle but you know if you've been in
this space any
period of time you know these are
four-year cycles that
this obviously happens on yeah for sure
um okay so just about you i want to know
um so you're
doing an amazing job with try lolly
um you're an absolute pr marketing
where's like i think you're incredible
um what's your
goal like what's your overall kind of
dream personally or for lolly or
possibly um
god that's so hard i because part of it
is with lolly
i do want to see
the lolly op on every person's phone
eventually also the app is sort of live
for thousands of people but it's rolling
out to
thousands of more at the end of the
month so be fully live across
you know the united states everyone can
have the ability to own bitcoin that
really is something that
makes me happy and really the while
while the
price and obviously i was interested in
bitcoin because it was
you know i was young and wanted to make
money the real technology behind
it and what it can do and what
cryptocurrency can do
for millions of people around the world
is something that really
resonates with me and so i've been
writing a lot of op-eds but i would like
to do
i would probably really like to start a
non-profit eventually if i was
successful and didn't really need money
to help sort of the causes that i'm very
passionate about and so
i think there's a lot of communities out
there in the united states
that i would start with first because i
think a lot of people look outside
of the united states sometimes to go
help when there's a lot of people
hurting within yeah
right now and so charity starts at home
as they say grows at home
it starts with yourself sort of your
family and your friends and helping and
loving the people that are hard to love
you know first and then reaching out
from there and helping other communities
so
there's a lot of places i just heard
about the
indigenous pop population in the united
states that is really
sort of forgotten about here there's
places like flint michigan
um in the united states that still don't
have great water
you know there's a lot of places in the
united states that are not mostly the
cities
are really hurting so i'd like to do
something where i could potentially give
back to other people
and eventually expand out outside the
united states um
if that was if i had the time to do it
but um
i also would love to live on a beach too
i want a short house like my
grandmother's shore house that i'm in
right now
but um that's that's hopefully when uh
lolly ipos
well keep stacking their sats yeah
so where can people find you how can
everyone stay up to date with you
yes you can follow me at the name listed
below at aubrey strobel
and then i am you know we follow the
twitter account too because we put a lot
of
hard work into those tweets so follow at
triloli
and then download lolly lolly.com
and yeah i'm mostly on uh twitter but i
i saw that you also you hit like 10k on
instagram recently and then i just hit
10k and i was like i've done
you've actually like built up a like a
following there
and i need to like try to build some
following
um on my personal account for bitcoin
but we also have a great instagram
account for
lolly which is what i said earlier about
the meme review
and so if you're into bitcoin memes go
over to instagram
if only for the memes and follow lolly
there
that's great aubrey thank you so much
it's been so good talking to you
i find this whole topic fascinating i
think you're doing such an incredible
job with tri lolly
um so thank you so much for coming on
thank you so much for having me this is
great
absolute pleasure and guys don't forget
to tune in next week
because it's great as always we'll see
you then bye